[MUSIC PLAYING]
SHERICE TORRES: Good
afternoon, everyone.
Thank you so much for joining
us for today's talk at Google.
I'm Sherice Torres.
I'm a marketing
director working on
our corporate social
responsibility programs,
including environment.
So this is an issue that's
very near and dear to my heart.
And I'm happy to be
here to introduce you
to Katharine Wilkinson.
Katharine is the author
of "Project Drawdown",
and I have a feeling
most of you in the room
and on the live stream are
familiar with the book.
But for those of
you who aren't, let
me give you a little
bit of a synopsis,
and then Katharine will walk
you through more details.
So the drawdown is the
most comprehensive plan
ever proposed to
reverse global warming.
It was released on April 18.
It is the number one new
release in climatology on Amazon
and a Top 10 New York
Times Nonfiction list.
And it's the most tactical plan
yet describing 100 real life
ways to address and
reverse climate change.
But enough from me.
You didn't come
to hear me speak.
I'm going to pass
it on to Katharine,
and then we will go to
question and answer.
Katharine, it's all yours.
KATHARINE WILKINSON:
Thanks, yeah.
Hi, all, in the room
and in the ether.
Thank you so much, Sherice.
I am excited to be
with you all today
to share a little bit
about our work at project.
Drawdown.
Obviously the 100 most
significant solutions
to climate change, we
won't cover all of them.
But we'll go through
some good content
and then dive into questions.
So there's a basic story
that we have been telling one
another about climate change
in recent decades, which
is it's bad.
It's going to get really bad.
We are headed towards a
potentially unlivable planet
and ill-equipped as a
species to change course.
Please change your light bulbs
and recycle your Coke cans,
and also cross your
fingers that we'll
have some silver bullet
technology or policy
solution that'll save the day.
There are reasons
for this story,
but it tends to leave us
feeling overwhelmed, paralyzed,
depressed, afraid,
hopeless, guilty.
None of these things
are good foundations
for action, when, of course,
action is exactly what we
need to be engaged in.
And the individual actions
that are sort of sent our way
as suggestions, changing light
bulbs and recycling Coke cans,
feel just wildly out of
step with the magnitude
of the problem.
So it really does sort of feel
like, well, all you can do--
if you don't happen to be
a utility company or a car
manufacturer-- is cross
your fingers and hope.
There's also an
underlying narrative,
I think, here
about human beings,
which is that we are terrible,
horrible, no good, very
bad, greedy, lazy, incompetent,
intransigent, and all the rest.
Again, maybe there are some
reasons for that story,
but it isn't the whole story.
On the other side of
the story is really
what we try to bring to life
in this book, "Drawdown".
Drawdown is the product of a
nonprofit living, research,
and communications project
on climate solutions
called Project Drawdown,
which is actually
just based in Sausalito.
If you think about
global warming
as kind of the ultimate problem
statement, for many years
our founder and
executive director
and editor of the book,
Paul Hawken, really wrestled
with a set of
persistent questions
in the face of problem, problem,
problem, problem, which was,
do we actually know what
we're supposed to be doing?
Do we have a list?
Do we have a sense of
apples to apples comparison
of existing solutions,
technologies, and practices
that we already know work,
that are already proven?
And then how much could
they each contribute?
If we scaled them
vigorously but plausibly
between now and
mid-century, let's say,
how much of the needle
can they each move
when it comes to
addressing global warming?
So Paul being Paul, he
sort of pitched this notion
to lots of different
organizations and folks,
all of whom said, a
list would be great.
We're not in the
business of doing that.
And eventually Project Drawdown
was born to do the math
and answer these
questions, and then
ultimately to bring
the answers to life,
not in yet another dry and
impenetrable and wonky climate
report, but in a
way that we hope
is really accessible and
instructive and maybe
even inspiring for
anyone, and not
just for folks who think
of themselves as experts
on climate.
Drawdown is very much
a global collaboration.
These are photos of
research fellows.
We had over 60 research
fellows from six continents who
worked on the project to date
under the leadership of Chad
Frischmann, our research
director, over 130
and growing advisors who
are just incredible leading
experts in various aspects of
climate and climate action,
again, with global
representation,
an absolutely wonderful
board, and then a very small
but we think mighty staff.
So imagine this whole community
of folks behind this work.
I promise this will be
the only chart-ish slide.
This is purely an
illustration, but I
want to just talk about what's
behind this name drawdown.
To state the obvious,
climate change
is caused by a rising
concentration of greenhouse
gases in the atmosphere.
We hit 402 parts per million
of carbon dioxide last year
and rising.
Last time concentrations of
carbon dioxide were this high,
human beings weren't around.
So we're very much living
in terra nova already.
So for us, we use
the term drawdown
to refer to the point in time at
which greenhouse gases could--
hopefully will--
peak and then begin
to decline on a
year-to-year basis.
So you hear a lot
in the climate space
about slowing emissions,
or stopping emissions,
or stabilizing at
a particular level.
And when Paul and our team
stepped back and said,
OK, if we're already
living in terra nova
at 402 parts per million,
the idea of stabilizing there
seems a bit wacky.
Maybe that's where we'll end up,
but let's actually put forward
a goal that is focused on
that tipping point where
we then head back
towards conditions
that are most conducive
for life on this planet.
So that's what
drawdown is about.
What we found as we
got into this work
is that actually, human
beings have been hard at work
developing a plan
to achieve drawdown.
We just didn't realize that
that's what we were doing.
So we've been out in backyards
and schools, fields, forests,
laboratories, companies,
communities, testing, learning,
refining, and then trying again.
And along the way, as we've been
dabbling in climate solutions,
there's been an incredible
body of data and peer reviewed
research that has been
built up about these various
technologies and practices.
So our job at Project Drawdown
wasn't to take a whiteboard
and invent a plan.
It was about going out and
codifying the collective wisdom
that already exists in
humanity, the things
that we already know how to
do and we understand why they
work, why they don't work,
what their economics are,
et cetera, et cetera, and
then to codify and synthesize
that collective wisdom, and
then make projections using
that incredible body of material
to understand how much can
solution x, y, or z move the
needle between now and 2050.
Just the littlest bit more
of kind of context setting.
Solutions are
solutions because they
do one or both of two things.
So they either avoid
sending greenhouse gases up
into the atmosphere,
whether that's
through energy
efficiency, replacing
fossil fuels, or other,
more polluting technologies
with clean alternatives,
reducing consumption,
protecting land and
ecosystems, and/or
they bring carbon dioxide back
home to earth through, turns
out, the ultimate carbon
capture and sequestration
technology of photosynthesis--
the world has actually already
really figured this out--
and bringing carbon back home
and storing it in plants, soil,
biomass.
So we often tend to get
into this trap of talking
about carbon as bad, carbon as
evil, when actually carbon is
a fundamental and vital
building block of life.
It's just a problem
of what we have
done with it, which is to
say, we've taken it from here
and we've sent too
much of it up there.
So the issue really is
about is about balance
more than anything.
And then the solutions are
organized into sectors.
So energy, food, women and
girls, buildings and cities,
land use, transport,
and materials.
There are 80 solutions that
fall into these sectors,
and you can think of
them as trains that
have already left the station.
So they're technologies
and practices
that we already see working.
They're already growing,
they're already scaling,
not everywhere, but
they are proven,
and they have potential
to grow significantly
and at a reasonable cost
over the next 30 years.
And then we have 20
coming attractions.
So these are
technologies or practices
that are nascent,
they're evolving,
maybe they're still
very much in R&D.
And even if they are
being used effectively,
we don't have the
sufficient data from which
to make the same
kind of projections
as we did for the other 80.
So there's content in the book
about these coming attractions,
but no numbers tied to them.
Nonetheless, we're likely to
get some help from at least some
of these coming attractions
in the coming decades.
So if anyone is sort
of a betting type,
this would be a good
moment to jot down maybe
what you think the
top three sectors are.
If you have the book in your
hand in this room, no cheating.
But this is an interesting one.
We certainly have lots
of surprises on this.
This is what a
solution looks like.
This is number 69 of
80, electric bikes.
This is a bicycle mechanic in
Berlin taking out his latest
e-bike model for a spin.
You can see that it combines
pedals and also a motor.
This portrait, I just
think, is beautiful.
This is a Daasanach woman, which
is an ethnic group in Sudan
and Ethiopia.
She and other women
in her village
have started kind of gathering
bottle caps, SIM cards, sort
of the detritus of 21st
century human civilization,
and making these beautiful
headdresses and jewelry out
of them.
This is the photograph that we
used for household recycling,
which comes in at number 55.
Number nine is
probably something
that folks have not heard of.
I had not.
It's silvopasture, which comes
from the Latin words for forest
and grazing.
So conventional wisdom
sort of tells us
that trees and cows don't mix.
But actually, what we see
is that the integration
of livestock and trees can
create incredibly resilient
and symbiotic systems that
benefit farmers because they
have additional products
that are coming to market
at different timelines.
They're better
insulated from risk
in the face of drought or
extreme weather events.
When it comes to climate,
what's really powerful
is that if you compare a
pasture with trees to a pasture
without trees, the
pasture with trees
sequesters five to
10 times more carbon
than its treeless brethren.
So trees are kind of
the secret sauce here.
And this turns out to have
absolutely enormous potential.
I'll just talk quickly
about the numbers
that you're seeing
on these slides.
So in the upper right, you've
got the reduced CO2 emissions
if this solution is scaled
vigorously but plausibly
between 2020 and 2050.
If there are solutions,
which there are,
that address other
greenhouse gases--
nitrous oxide,
methane, et cetera--
then those impacts
are translated
into their equivalent
in carbon dioxide.
So we're able to have an
apples to apples comparison
and ranking of all of them.
A gigaton-- probably this
is very evident at Google--
a gigaton is a billion tons.
A cow weighs about a ton, so
this is a pretty good visual
for talking about this.
So one gigaton is
about a billion cows
worth of carbon dioxide.
For reference, we emitted
about 36 gigatons in 2016,
so about 36 billion cows worth.
So you can silvopasture
comes in just a bit
below an annual
year's emissions.
That obviously
drives the ranking,
in this case number
nine out of 80.
And then in the
bottom left, you've
got the incremental cost
to implement the solution.
So what's the additional
cost of purchasing
an electric vehicle as opposed
to a gasoline car, for example?
And in the bottom right,
the net operational savings,
or, in a handful of
cases, cost over 30 years.
So again, what do
you save from driving
an electric vehicle as opposed
to driving a gasoline car?
Or in the case of silvopasture,
what's the additional revenue
that a farmer gets from running
a silvopasture operation as
opposed to a regular
pasture operation?
This is the top 20.
There are, I think, some
really interesting insights
and surprises, and some
things you would expect,
and some really
unsung heroes that
end up landing in this list.
So I thought we might
just talk through what
some of those things
are, and then we
can kind of come back to other
things if we don't cover them.
The first thing that I think
is a really powerful ah-ha
from this work is that food is
eight of the top 20 solutions,
and it's actually the largest
sector overall in terms
of its potential impact.
Just a bit more than 320
gigatons of reduced carbon
dioxide by mid-century.
And what we include
in that sector
is what we produce,
how we produce it,
and then also reducing
waste so that we don't
have to produce so very much.
And that's where I think
maybe we should start.
Reduced food waste, I
think, is pretty compelling,
coming in at number three of 80.
So about 1/3 of the food that
we produce around the world,
and about 40% in the
US, is not consumed.
And that excess food that's
then wasted generates about 8%
of annual greenhouse
gas emissions.
So it's really sizable
chunk of the pie.
In regions of high
income, we have a tendency
to waste by choice.
So we overbuy.
Portions are huge.
We forget about leftovers
in the back of the fridge.
Consumers and retailers
reject ugly produce.
We have best by, sell
by, consume by labels
that actually, by and
large, are totally
disconnected from safety, so we
throw perfectly good food away.
In regions of lower
income, it tends
to be a question of
infrastructure and markets.
So waste happens earlier
in the food chain,
if you will, and
it has a tendency
to be related to storage
or labor, et cetera.
What you see here in this photo
are ugly potatoes and carrots
that have been sent to the
rubbish heap in England.
We invest a lot of
resources into food,
whether we eat it or not.
This is sort of stating the
obvious, but seeds, water,
energy, land, fertilizer,
labor, capital, on and on.
We harvest it, we process
it, we ship it, we store it,
we consume it, or we cook it,
perhaps, don't consume it.
Sometimes we end up
cutting down forest
to grow more food
that we don't eat.
And then oftentimes
that food ends up
in a landfill, where it is
potentially generating methane
as it decomposes.
So you've got all of
these different dynamics
of greenhouse gases
getting generated
through this kind of
partial life cycle of food.
And that's what makes this
such a huge opportunity.
In France, pretty simple.
They simply say it's
illegal for grocery stores
to throw food away.
So guess what?
It ends up in the hands of
folks who need it and might not
otherwise have it, or it ends
up being shoveled into livestock
operations to feed livestock.
So lots of ways in to
impacting the solution.
But I think what's really
exciting about this one coming
in at number three is that
it's something we can all
have an impact on immediately
and at no cost, which
I think is pretty exciting.
And the same is true, actually,
of solution number four.
This is a painting
some may recognize
of Vertumnus, who was the
Roman god of seasons and plant
growth.
This solution is also completely
free and in our control,
and we can adopt it the second
we walk out of the room, which
is plant-rich diet.
So coming in at
about 66 gigatons,
this is essentially doing the
math on Michael Pollan's advice
to eat food, not too
much, mostly plants.
Raising livestock
contributes about 1/5
of our global emissions.
Ruminants-- cows, sheep--
are the most prolific offenders,
because they have a rumen.
And They have a second stomach
in which cellulose ferments
and it creates methane, which
mostly comes out as burps,
contrary to popular opinion.
If cattle were their
own nation, they
would be the third largest
emitter after China and the US.
So this is no small problem.
Some have probably
seen in the last week
the article that came out in
"The Atlantic" and elsewhere
that if Americans were simply
to swap beans for beef,
we could reach up to
3/4 of our targets
under the Paris
Agreement by 2020.
No technology required.
This is powerful stuff.
Of course, dietary
change is hard.
It's cultural and it's personal.
I'm from the south, and nobody
wants to give up barbecue.
So we did not model here
world becoming vegan.
What we modeled here was animal
protein and calorie consumption
coming down in
places like the US,
where it's much too
high, and actually,
calories and protein going
up in parts of the world
where malnutrition is an issue.
So this is more
about the whole world
coming into a healthier
diet that ends up also,
of course, having the benefits
of lowering chronic disease
and health care
costs, et cetera.
It also includes in
this number the impact
of avoided deforestation
that would otherwise
happen to grow more corn and
soybeans to feed more cows.
Energy comes in with
five of the top 20.
It's the second
largest sector overall.
And what I think is really
fascinating here, and worth
pausing on, is that
energy has the tendency
to just dominate our
conversations about climate
change.
In large part, that's because
energy has caused so very
much of the problem,
and it may continue
to do so if we don't get a
grip on fossil fuel emissions.
So changing energy
sources and energy systems
is absolutely critical.
But we would be remiss to
think that if we do that,
we sort of have a hall
pass into the 22nd century.
Even if we got to 100% renewable
energy, it cannot, by itself,
solve global warming.
So I think that's really
important context.
I love this photo so much.
This is an Uru family that
lives on Lake Titicaca.
You can see just
a little bit here.
They live on a reed island.
And they've just gotten
this solar panel, which
means that they'll
have electricity
at their home for
the first time,
and the girls will not
have to do their homework
by kerosene lamp anymore.
So you can imagine
kerosene lamps
in a reed house on a reed
island is not a great recipe.
So this is rooftop
solar, which, of course,
has incredible potential
in higher income
parts of the world.
But as a form of
distributed energy,
it has incredible potential
for the 1.1 billion people
that don't have
access to electricity
or an electric grid.
So this is sort of one of
those great examples where
there are just layers and
layers of positive co-benefits
in these solutions, greenhouse
gases just being one of those.
This one's also, I
think, really incredible.
You see the potential
savings in home energy costs
over 30 years of
almost $3.5 trillion.
So again, another great
example of where economics
are taking off and are
really going to push forward
the scaling of these solutions.
Three of the top
20 solutions fall
into what we call land use,
so non-agricultural land use.
And these are solutions
that are focused
on restoring, protecting,
and harnessing
the power of land and ecosystems
for carbon sequestration.
We're really just going through
a lot of my personal favorites
from the book.
Anyone have a guess
on what this might be?
This is a harvested peatland.
So peatlands are
wetland ecosystems.
We also call them bonds, mires.
They are just 3% of
the world's land area,
but they're second only to
oceans in the amount of carbon
that they store.
And they hold twice as much
as all of the worlds forests.
So peatlands need
some love, you know?
They are essentially
made of layers and layers
and layers and layers of
decomposing plant material.
So that's where you
get all of the carbon.
If you left peat alone for
long enough under the right
conditions, it
would become coal.
When we were working on
the book, it was like,
how do we give peatllands
some sparkle and some magic?
It turns out that
the Irish poet Seamus
Heaney has written a bunch of--
wrote, I guess, in the 60s--
some really fabulous poems
about bog land in Ireland.
And he describes, in
one of these poems,
"the ground itself is kind black
butter", which sort of then,
all of a sudden, tells
you everything you
need to know about peatlands.
That kind black
butter makes them
under threat from farming
and forestry and fire.
So what we've looked
at here is the impact
of expanding the acreage
of protected peatlands.
Again, we're not talking about
a huge amount of land area,
but it's a lot of bang for your
buck in terms of protection.
And what's also on this
slide that you haven't
seen on others,
this 1,230 gigatons,
that would be the
protected stock of carbon
that the world's peatlands would
then hold as of mid-century.
So another important
piece of the puzzle.
The number one solution
is refrigeration.
Sort of deeply unsexy,
I'm sorry to say.
It focuses on chemical
refrigerants in our AC systems,
our refrigerators,
our cold chains.
Folks probably remember that
in 1987, the Montreal Protocol
began to phase out of
chlorofluorocarbons, CFCs,
which were, at that time, the
dominant chemical refrigerant
that we used.
Their primary replacement
chemical, HFCs, great,
on the one hand because they
have almost no negative impact
on the ozone layer.
But they turn out to be 1,000
or more times as powerful
as carbon dioxide in terms of
their global warming potential.
So solve one problem, end
up contributing to another.
Last year, the world
came to an agreement
to amend the Montreal Protocol
so the phase-out of HFCs
is going to be coming first
in higher income countries,
and then in a couple
of subsequent waves.
Scientists think
that that move alone
could reduce global warming
by half a degree Celsius.
So this is no small thing.
And what we've looked
at in this model
is the potential to manage
the HFCs that are already
in circulation and that will
come into circulation even
as the world moves towards
and through phase-out.
So basically addressing
leaks and managing
what you do with these chemicals
at the point of disposal,
which is when about
90% of emissions occur.
So really, really powerful.
Again, because of that high
global warming potential
in terms of carbon
equivalent, this
comes in very high at almost 90
gigatons of avoided emissions.
This is a section that has
surprised a lot of folks, women
and girls.
Solutions number six and seven,
educating girls and family
planning.
These are essentially
solutions that
focus on advancing women's
rights and opportunity
and well-being, and then
the positive ripple effects
that come out of that in terms
of the planet, of emissions,
but also lots of other
positive societal effects.
So what we've looked
at here is the impact
of closing the gaps that
exist in the world on access
to education and access to
voluntary family planning.
So this is really a solution
that begins and ends
with rights, and then
the emissions impacts
are side effects.
This is just another, I
think, really beautiful photo.
This is a young girl who
is in school in Kenya.
But 130 million girls around the
world are not in school today,
and that's especially a problem
in secondary classrooms.
Of course, education
is an intrinsic right,
and it feels very
obvious to say,
but it lays an absolutely
vital foundation for our lives.
So what we see with
more education is
that women have higher
wages and better
upward mobility, maternal
and infant mortality go down,
rates of HIV, AIDS,
and malaria go down.
Farms are more productive.
They're less likely to
be forced into marriage.
On and on and on and on and on.
It also turns out that women
who have more years of education
choose to have fewer
children, more actively
engage in the use
of contraception,
and their children
are healthier.
So if you look at a woman
who has no years of schooling
compared to 12
years of schooling,
the difference is four to
five children per woman.
I think it's really,
really important
to be clear that in the
poorest countries in the world,
and in parts of the world where
girls are having the hardest
time getting
educated, per capita
greenhouse gas emissions
are very, very low.
They are a fraction of
what they are in the US
and in parts of the world
that have done the most
to cause the problem
of global warming
and have the most work
to do to address it.
So these absolutely have to
be seen in the context of all
of these other solutions.
But still, when you're talking
about changes in fertility
rates, you're talking
about a difference
in the number of feet making
their carbon footprints
as of mid-century.
And when you add that up, the
cumulative effect is powerful.
So what we've looked at
here is the difference
between hitting the
UN's high population
projection as opposed to its
medium population projection.
And that difference is
essentially all comes down
to family planning.
Education and then
contraception or are
two components that really
add up to drive that impact.
It also turns out
that education is
really powerful for shoring up
resilience to climate impacts.
So this is another
one of the solutions
that has kind of many, many,
many layers of benefits.
So for example, education
is the number one factor
for girls and women
surviving natural disasters.
So more education,
you're less likely to be
injured or displaced or
killed when a storm hits.
And that's obviously just
one of the many impacts
that's headed our way
with climate change,
even as we work to address it.
So if you add up educating
girls and family planning,
it turns out that actually
empowering women and girls
is the number one solution
to global warming.
Despite this being
the era of Buzzfeed,
it is not actually
about the number one
or the top five or the top 10.
We need all of these
solutions, and we
have all of these solutions.
So I just want to zip
through a few more photos
because they're just wonderful.
We can grow the acreage
of protected forests
like the Great Bear Rainforest
in British Columbia,
which is just an incredible
success story on this front.
This is a lovely, hungry
Kermode bear eating salmon
in the Great Bear Rainforest.
We can build more offshore
and onshore wind farms.
This is the
Sheringham Shoal Wind
Farm, which is 88 turbines off
the coast of Norfolk, England.
This is not photo-shopped.
This is actually an
athlete in training.
We can install more green
roofs and cool roofs.
This one, I think, is
particularly lovely
overlooking Basel, Switzerland.
This is the roof of
the hospital there.
We can spread a set of
actually very simple practices
for growing rice in a way
that increases yields but also
reduces methane production
through the growing
cycle of rice.
And then, as I
mentioned earlier,
we will have some help
from coming attractions.
So this is one that we are
already getting help from.
I think we'll see the
first high rise wood
building in Portland, Oregon.
It's been permitted and I
think construction has started.
I'm just think this
one is so fascinating.
So there are now these high
performance wood products
that are as strong, and
even more fire resistant,
than steel and concrete, which
I found just wild and shocking.
Go read about this.
It really is quite amazing.
And they have the double
benefit of sequestering carbon
in that wood.
Dry wood is about 50% carbon.
So if you've got
wood that's locked
into the structure
of a building that's
going to stand for a
long time, that carbon
is being held there.
And also you're able
to avoid the emissions
of steel and concrete,
which are incredibly high.
Combined, they're at least
10% of our annual emissions.
So really, really amazing.
This is just another--
now I'm just showing you
guys a couple cool ones
because I think they're fun.
We might be able to use
marine permaculture arrays.
So imagine sort of giant
lattice-like structures
from which we can grow
floating kelp forests that
have the benefit of
sequestering carbon really
quickly, but also creating
habitat for fish and sea life
in parts of the oceans
where basically they're
now sort of dead
zones, potentially
producing food and fuel.
There's a lot of exciting
opportunity here.
Maybe we will end up
pursuing the proposal
of a pair of father
son scientists
in Siberia who are
testing and advocating
for repopulating the
Arctic with herbivores,
perhaps even
recreated mammoths--
there are folks also
working on this--
that could prevent
permafrost from melting.
I'll let you read
about that in the book
because it's quite fun.
I think you can look
at these 100 solutions
and think, oh my gosh,
we have so much to do.
But you can also look at them,
I think, and see, oh my gosh,
there's so much we can do.
There are literally so many
ways into having an impact
on this issue, so
many footholds,
and so many realms of agency
for literally everyone, which
I think is really,
really exciting.
The toolbox that we have
is already so, so, so rich.
We started with
this dominant story
arc of doom and
gloom, the one that
tells us that human beings
are terrible, horrible, no
good, very bad.
When you come through
this lens of solutions,
the other side of
the story, I think,
becomes really clear, which
is that human beings are also
creative and compassionate and
collaborative and committed,
and every now and again,
brilliant and pretty gutsy.
And I think if we want
to stay courageous
and driven in the face
of climate change, which
we need to do, and if we
want to invite more people
into this work,
which we need to do,
then I think we need to hear
and tell and own that story.
The doom and gloom at higher
and higher volume and frequency
is not exactly a
great pickup line.
And this is a true story.
It's a story of what we are
already doing, what we can do,
and I think, also, about
who we are as human beings.
The climate movement
basically has been giving
and I have a nightmare speech
for the last 30 or 40 years.
It's a really easy
speech to give, actually,
when you look at the science of
the problem and the timelines
that we're on.
Screaming "I have a nightmare",
really doable and reasonable.
But it's not working
as a strategy.
We need the clear and credible
vision that's actually worth
fighting for.
What are we talking about
beyond inverting catastrophe?
What's the dream?
And I'm very, very
hopeful that drawdown
begins to help
articulate that vision,
makes a contribution
towards that vision.
For me personally,
it's a vision that's
grounded in honoring
the sacredness of life,
human and non-human
life, on this planet.
The solutions for
reducing greenhouse gases
are also a means of building a
more resilient, more equitable,
more prosperous,
more vibrant world.
And I think when we
get locked in talking
about just emissions, we lose
this bigger picture about what
the world that we're trying
to create actually looks like.
We already have the technical
capacity to achieve drawdown.
I think that's a really,
really important takeaway
from this book.
So the question, then,
for all of us, I think,
is how do we cultivate the
human capacity to get there?
How do you stay in the work?
How do you keep
making change happen?
We have at least 100
ways in, as this book
shows, to moving the
needle on global warming.
So the question that I hope
it poses for all of you
is, which one will you pick?
Who might you work with?
What talents might you deploy?
There is such an incredible
opportunity for impact
and a role for everyone to play.
The work to create this
book, and the ongoing work
of keeping these models living
and evolving and improving,
and keeping the
communication living
and evolving and
improving, is complex.
But actually, I think
the moral of the story
is really, really simple,
which is that it's not game
over for climate change and
global warming and the planet.
It's actually game on.
[APPLAUSE]
SHERICE TORRES:
Thank you, Katharine.
So we are going to move
into a Q&A session.
We have a couple of
prepared questions,
and then we're going to go to
the Dory and to the audience.
So if you give us
one second, we're
going to mosey on over here, and
we're going to move the camera.
So I'm vamping a
little bit here.
Work with me.
KATHARINE WILKINSON:
And if anyone actually
did take the bet, you can see
how you did on the ranking.
SHERICE TORRES: Oh, fantastic.
So I want to make sure
to save a lot of time
for Dory questions-- oh, I'm
getting a little feedback--
for Dory questions and for
questions from the audience.
So I'm just going
to ask a couple
from our prepared
questions here.
We've heard the
science, and we've
heard the background and what
drew Project Drawdown together.
We'd love to hear a little bit
more about your personal story.
What drew you both to
Drawdown in particular,
but to climate
change in general?
KATHARINE WILKINSON: In general.
So when I was 16, I lived
in the woods for four months
with 25 other high schoolers.
We lived in one-room cabins
in the woods and chopped wood
to heat those cabins and
worked in the garden.
And there was a
really heavy emphasis
in that program, called the
Outdoor Academy in Western
North Carolina,
on sustainability,
on natural history and
environmental education.
It was when I also
started reading
the work of important
authors in this space.
Basically, I became
indoctrinated and kind of
shifted from loving the outdoors
to wanting to live and work
in a way that helped us address
these challenges that we're
facing as a global community.
I went on to pursue
that in undergrad.
I worked for a big
nonprofit out of undergrad
and was really struck
by the way in which
the environmental movement,
sitting mostly, as it does,
in New York and San Francisco,
sort of talks right past most
of America.
So I was spending a
lot of time in kind
of stereotypically mega-church,
NASCAR, country music land.
And that gap between the
environmental movement
and most of America,
and people who
really do care about land and
place, just really hit me.
And so I really wanted to
grapple with other ways in.
And it turned out that that
year, the Evangelical Climate
Initiative launched, which
was an effort by a large group
of more moderate
evangelical leaders
to mobilize their
community, which,
depending on how you do
the math, is 1/4 to 1/3
of US population, to
address global warming.
I went on to do a PhD at Oxford,
trying to kind of understand
and unpack that phenomenon.
Where did this come
from and how were they
framing the issue, and to what
degree was it resonating or not
with the church going public?
And after doing that
work, I was like,
I cannot work in climate change.
This is really depressing.
And finishing up grad
school kind of coincided
with what looked like our best
opportunity in a generation
to get federal climate
legislation passed in the US.
Passed in the House. it
didn't get through the Senate.
And then there were
sort of the dissolution
of global talks in Copenhagen.
And I just was like,
this feels like banging
one's head against a wall
when sort of everything
hinges on global agreements, or
what Washington can agree on.
So I sort of stepped back
from it for a few years.
And then, through a consulting
project, met Paul, our founder.
And immediately the sort
of ethos and perspective
of Drawdown spoke to me, both
from my academic background
and my analysis
of what I thought
was missing in the
climate movement
and where it needed
to be stronger.
But also personally.
I had been really tugged at
a sense of responsibility
and possibility to
come back into making
an impact in this space.
And so kind of the
combination of those two
really just sang to me.
So it's been fun to be--
instead of sitting
in an academic seat
kind of analyzing
the stories that we
tell about the world and
our relationship to it--
to actually be embedded in
this really amazing team
that's doing the work
to shape those stories.
SHERICE TORRES: Awesome.
So you talked about a
key legislative moment
that was part of your journey.
And I think everyone in here
is probably thinking about--
and our live
stream-- is thinking
about our current political
climate and the impact
on the environmental
movement there,
for the fact that
the word climate
change is systematically
being removed from lots
of documents and papers.
Would love to hear your
thoughts about climate change
in this current
political environment.
KATHARINE WILKINSON: Yeah.
It does not feel
good to be here.
I mean, I think everyone's
hope was that the second Bush
Administration was going
to be the worst that we
saw on this front, and that
we had hit at a turning point.
Obviously that was wrong.
So I want to be honest
about the bad news, which
is that given the science
and given the timelines,
we need every single part of
society pulling its weight
to address this issue.
We're not going to get
that from Washington.
But the good news is that
actually, essentially all
of the progress that's been
made in this country on climate
has been done in the absence
of leadership in Washington.
Even when you had the Obama
Administration pushing,
they were getting
thwarted and blocked,
and a lot of those
initiatives have just
been caught up in court.
So actually the leaders on this,
cities, states, businesses,
communities, have been leading,
they've been having an impact,
and they're going
to keep doing it.
And what we saw with the
announcement about the plan
to pull out of the
Paris agreement
was a doubling down both
from leaders in the US
and also the rest of the world.
And I think that was the fear.
If the US pulls out,
does everything crumble?
And basically, everyone
said, yeah, no, we're in.
And we're actually add
on to onto that bet.
So I think that's
the great news.
I think also we see
some really hopeful news
around the economics.
So a report just
recently came out
that solar and wind
will be the cheapest
form of electricity generation
in the world within three
years.
So they're already
at parity or cheaper
in some parts of the world.
But the cost declines that have
come around solar and turbine
technology have happened so much
faster than anyone predicted.
So I think we're
starting to see some
of these kind of wind at our
back, I guess, of economics.
And even probably a sort
of half-baked businessman
in the White House
could figure out
that those economics make sense.
SHERICE TORRES: So you
talked a little bit
about how climate
change has been
positioned for individuals.
It's about recycling
and electric cars
or using an electric bike.
Talk to us about the relative
importance and different roles
that individuals versus
collective action
have to play in this.
KATHARINE WILKINSON: Yeah.
I think it's been a real miss
of the environmental movement
to focus so much on
individual action.
Look, individual action matters.
I think it matters
more as a way to enact
your values as it does impact.
So I've been vegetarian
since I was 16.
But for me, that's
partially a mechanism
for reflecting on what
it is that I care about
and reflecting on my ethic
at least three meals a day.
So I think these things matter,
but collective action is really
where the rubber hits the road.
And that can be
collective action
in the form of movements.
You see really
incredible work being
done by Bill McKibben and
350.org, which is focused more
on how do we keep fossil
fuels in the ground, which
is really important work.
Citizens Climate Lobby has
built up a really incredible
grassroots effort
to try and cultivate
that political will in
every congressional district
in the country.
So you know, if that's a
place that you feel called
to take action, I think
that's a really great way in,
but also through business, and
also through neighborhoods.
But we're probably never
going to see more than 5%
or 10% of people really care and
really take voluntary action.
So the question is, how
do you shift structures,
and how do you shift bigger
institutions and organizations
to make change?
And what we see from
social movements
is it doesn't take that
many people to pull together
into a collective voice to
be able to move the needle.
SHERICE TORRES: Awesome.
So let's jump in to some
questions from the Dory.
So first question we
have is, corporations
have a big responsibility
for climate impact.
Are there good examples
of corporations
that have taken steps
to align profitability
with protecting the planet
from climate change,
and what can consumers
and Google do
to apply additional influence
and pressure on that front?
KATHARINE WILKINSON:
So I'm sort of
geeked out that this
would be an example I
wanted to talk to you about.
And you have their
carpet in this room.
This is a company
called Interface.
They're a public company,
but they're smallish.
They're headquartered
in Georgia,
and they have been an
absolute vanguard and pioneer
in sustainability on business.
Their late founder
and CEO actually read
one of Paul's earlier books,
"The Ecology of Commerce",
in the mid-90s and had
this sort of revelation of,
we have been raping and
pillaging the planet,
and someday titans of industry
who have acted like me
are going to go to jail.
And he set Interface
on a course-- they
no idea how they would do it.
It's a petrochemical-based
carpet manufacturing company--
to get to zero environmental
footprint by 2020.
It's been an amazing journey.
And now you see companies
like Unilever saying,
we're able to do what we're
doing because Interface
opened up the space to do this
and showed the example that you
can improve financial
performance at the same time
as you're dramatically shifting
your environmental performance.
So 2020 aspiration of
zero, mission zero,
has been their focus.
And they now have
asked what does
it look like to go beyond
zero to actually net
good, net planetary
good as a company?
So they have
launched what they're
calling Climate Takeback as
their next corporate mission,
which is how do
we actually engage
in this process of
pulling carbon back down
out of the atmosphere?
How do we do drawdown
as a company, where
we're pulling more
greenhouse gases down
than we're sending up?
Again, it's a big
and bold mission,
and they don't know how
they will get there.
Sequestering carbon in their
products is probably something.
They're already working
with Janine Benyus
and brilliant biomimicry
team around how do you
design a factory like a forest
so that it actually exhales
net good into the world?
I think these are the kinds
of really big questions
we should ask.
Lots of companies now
are doing good stuff
on efficient operations.
But how do you really take
that next big, bold, pioneering
step, I think, is the question.
So our next question
from the Dory--
and I'll go to the
audience in one minute--
talks about how you
gave lots of examples
of how to reduce the
acceleration of temperature
change around the world.
The question is, are
there folks out there--
researchers,
nonprofits, grassroots
groups-- that are forming
strategies around this,
and how can Googlers contribute?
And I will interrupt
once so I can say,
one way Googlers can
contribute exactly
by donating to Project Drawdown.
So if you're on the live
stream, you can actually go
to go/drawdown-donate
to make a donation.
And if you're in
the room here today,
when you go in the back of
the room to pick up your book,
we have a badge
reader where you can
make a donation right
from a payroll deduction,
so it's super easy.
And Project Drawdown is
the group behind this book,
so that's one way.
Are there some other folks
you can point to around,
you know, they're doing
really great work here
and we should look into
doing more work with them?
KATHARINE WILKINSON: Yeah.
So thank you for that.
We are a very
small organization,
so donations really do
have a big impact for us.
There are so many
organizations doing good work.
I mean, that is the
really exciting thing.
And obviously, we could
only include a smattering
of examples in this book.
What I hope that people
will do is use the book as,
like, a choose
your own adventure.
So clearly all of
these things have
impact, all of these
solutions have impact.
The need is really clear.
So then the question
is, what is it that
stokes a fire in your belly?
What's a way that you
want to contribute?
Is it with time,
talent, resources?
And kind of think about
that intersection.
The theologian
Frederick Buechner
called it "where
your deep gladness
meets the world's deep need".
Or if you don't know, flip
through the pages and pick one.
I mean, there are organizations
working on all these.
That's why they're all
growing and scaling already.
And so I think if
you focus on an area,
then it becomes OK,
well, yeah, I actually
really care about
family planning.
What are the organizations that
are doing good work on this?
Or are there startups advancing
cool things in this area?
Is Community x doing
something really powerful
that we could replicate here?
Those are the kinds of
questions I would ask.
I hate to be too
prescriptive, but also
keep an eye on our website
because, as you can imagine,
since the book
came out, we've had
lots of folks flooding in
with desires for partnerships
and collaboration.
I think actually there are some
conversations going on with x.
And so we're sort
of putting together
what that architecture
of collective impact
and different working groups
across different areas
may look like.
So tons of ways to plug in.
SHERICE TORRES: Any
questions in the room today?
Yeah.
Say your question
and I can repeat it.
Oh, we have a microphone.
Even better.
AUDIENCE: First of all,
thank you for coming here.
This was very inspiring.
So one of the texts
about global warming
that I've read that
really concerns
me is Bill McKibben's "Three
Numbers for Global Warming".
I don't know if you're
familiar with it,
but for people who
aren't, basically he
talks about three numbers.
The first one is two degrees
Celsius is the consensus
that scientists have agreed
that the temperature can rise
without horrific consequences.
Then 500 and something
gigatons of carbon dioxide
is how much carbon dioxide
that equivalents to.
And then the last number, which
is when I got really terrified,
is that, I think, 2,500, so
five times larger than the 500
that we can emit
for two Celsius.
So 2,500 is how much is
already planned in the economy
to be emitted in I don't
know how many next years.
So it's already in
companies' shares.
It's already people
are going out and--
it's oil that's already being
pulled out from the ground.
So I guess coming
down to the question
is, what are your
thoughts on that?
And do you think we may
have reached a point where,
even if we start doing
a bunch of actions,
it might be too late?
KATHARINE WILKINSON: So I
don't have a crystal ball.
So I don't know how
this is going to go.
The way I think
about it is, we don't
have any option other
than to go really
hard at solving the problem.
If you say, well,
game over, then what?
You're going to just
give up on humanity?
What do you do with that?
And what I appreciate
from Bill McKibben
and his work is, what
this has done for Bill is,
he is on the front
lines of trying to keep
fossil fuels in the ground.
For me if I only think
about those numbers of,
here's how much more we
can emit before we really
turn this planet
into a disaster zone,
and here's how much we're
planning on emitting,
and even worse than
that, here's how much
we could emit if we really went
for all of these fossil fuel
resources--
that's terrifying.
And for me, that place of
terror leaves me feeling
really frozen and paralyzed.
And I think it's an
important part of the story
to understand.
And if you only
read that chapter,
I think you miss
the bigger picture.
Bill wrote a really great
article in "Rolling Stone"
a few years ago called "Global
Warming's Terrifying New
Math", which is just
totally terrifying.
And I think we need to
be honest with ourselves
about the potential
of what's ahead.
But I think we have to be
really thoughtful about the rest
of the conversation that
we're building in with that.
So there was also a very
doom-and-gloomy piece
just recently in
"New York" magazine,
which my feeling is, if you're
going to do doom and gloom,
do it like that.
Just rip the bandage off
and just tell people.
It's like, this is
how bad it could be.
But what I didn't
like about that piece
was at the end of
it, he says, yeah,
but all these scientists
still have hope.
And they have hope because
maybe there'll be a carbon tax
and maybe we'll have some
geoengineering solutions.
And to me, I don't have faith
in either of those, necessarily.
I do have a lot of
faith in the things
we're already doing
that are already working
and our ability to
scale those things.
Maybe we'll get some
extra help, but I
don't think that's where
we should hang our hat.
So these are my thoughts.
We were talking about
this at lunch, actually.
There's an amazing
Quaker thought
leader named Parker
Palmer who talks
about the tragic gap
and the work of staying
in the tragic gap, which is
the space between the world
as it is and the world as
it could be or should be.
And it's really easy to flip out
into cynicism on the one side,
or it's really easy
to flip out into kind
of starry-eyed optimism,
like, gee whiz, you know,
everything's always
getting better,
and that there's work
to stay in the work.
And I think that it's
different for different people.
But if I only thought
about those numbers,
I would only stay in
tragedy and cynicism,
and I don't think I'd be
able to keep doing the work.
SHERICE TORRES: And I think on
that point, we're at 2 o'clock
and it's a great place to end.
So let's keep on in
that gap doing the work,
because through our actions--
and collective actions,
more importantly,
we can make a change.
So Katharine, thank
you so much for coming.
Thank you all for
attending and dialing in.
[APPLAUSE]